allez on va voir notre des piles et des
piles et chic à saint tropez
on va démarrer avec celle qui va être à
côté de vous papale à la côte et en fait
ok en fait le mettre là bas ok c'est
valérie benaïm vous la connaissez ah oui
j'ai déjà comme ça quand vous
l'apercevez vallée oui au chaud que
c'est une des plus marquants de
l'émission smart de l'émission arrive
tous très chic toujours bien coiffée
mais toujours à l'action est à dire qu
elle à laâyoune smara
d'accord il a trouvé smart elle m'a
coûté ma très bien beau regarder
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ça c'est saint tropez saint louis et
saint tropez s'assure mais ça c'est
plutôt ça c'est plutôt chaud
mais sans déconner en direct à natacha
jonças permet sans déconner
on dirait qu'elle a ramené démocrate
modéré qu'a l'a ramenée de l'après là
dans son sac non sans déconner badens
quelques ailes mais sans y
aller
je m'embarque un truc ça quand je vois
qu'on a des caméras déguisés en fantômes
non mais sans déconner c'est la ccga
qu'on est la seule chaîne open les
caméras vont son genre t'es où
allez on va accueillir un [ __ ] voilà
je vous rappelle que c'est un look saint
tropez à regarder vraiment
[Applaudissements]
c'est à deux avec ses longues à
jardinier à 131
coupet va couper des arbustes sans
déconner on dirait un gars on dirait un
gars dans les experts s'il veut passer
incognito
c'est derrière un arbuste comme à 125 ou
non mes frères et ça ça toi à la nettoie
si je peux donner un conseil montre tes
pieds vraiment dernier moment
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
ces montres tes pieds quand tu es sûr
que ces faits graves déplore questionner
aucune pièce en trop mais c'est quoi la
paix sociale ait choisi quoi servait la
pièce en gros t'es sur que c'est pas là
une lunette patel des lunettes noires
et
chapeau l'échappée dont la dame au
chapeau vous dire que j'ai parlé que de
cheveux ouais c'est bien là et
saint-tropez là à d'accord mais ça
trompez pas si jamais vu des mecs comme
ça dans when droite et centre au pied
[Rires]
on va accueillir avec la béatrice la
classe américaine
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
tromper saint louis s'est séparé s'il
tenait saint-tropez c'est par ici tu en
as un problème va retrouver va retourner
au parricide
ça franchement ça c'est joli ça c'est
pas mal franchement c'est ça vous la
robe non c'est pas moi il faudra la
rendre merci
gfr
franchement non mais bravo bravo qu'est
ce que vous en dites non c'est joli
c'est joli vous parlez la personne ou de
là les deux très jeunes du goût
il a dit la même chose pour des mots
très bon support aujourd'hui j'étais
vous je me méfierais
abbas à rennes en battant des eaux puis
la même démarche au plus
et le mieux c'est la juge vous n'avez
pas les mêmes pire
moment pour infor les pièces avec des
pays comme ça franchement rapport à oui
oui et son formidable mes pieds elles
vont d'orthez beige avec vous on se
réveille
sans déconner on vit un cauchemar on
va accueillir un ami bien genton
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
moi c'est pas nul c
franchement bon c'est kanye west à ça
près je te jure alors danser c'est vrai
c'est kanye west cola après ses sushis
saga qu'on va chercher du poisson
jusque là c'est kanye west après
sargasses et ouais je vais chercher du
poisson pané fait quoi la morue moi
c'est bon sinon si je te jure c'est un
truc ça s'appelle apéro dînatoire et
tapas du soleil
c'est un plus pour le côté fin d'aprèm
sans manches pour le soleil d'accord ça
c'est des bottes que j'ai piqué un
touriste allemand c'est sur ces bottes
ses bottes sa survie si en hiver ouais
par contre ça tu dois avoir le pied sur
la tête de ma mère tu sors ton pied
seigneur jésus s'intalle bris
[Rires]
avec lui à saint tropez avec les
taureaux copte d'assen fromagerie et
qu'on s'éloigne trop marginaux but lanta
des gars qui savent vous avez du sang
nectaire
mamers et moribond mais c'est pas mal
c'est mieux que d'habitude qui met
d'habitude c'est stylé aller géraldine
maillet
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c'est pas mal alors émis des petites
vans ouais c'est pas mal faire à pieds
nus et non à l adema
mère malade et y est ils sont plus beaux
que wade
sait rien si j'avais sous l'ère pas la
place de marconnet
je fais chauffer plus sur la tène le
maire joël musique et chants d'y mettre
son bien par des chocs en match comme
tu connais pas mais sans égal et parce
que le premier rendez-vous à mr x tu vas
voir les iem de ta meuf c'est toujours
une épreuve d'anglais sans déconner vous
avez vous fêté ses 7 cm
brière février alors admettons la femme
est sublime mais vraiment super en
revanche sur 10 à l'aller viendrez me
wade a par exemple les petits chanteurs
du quan on met les pieds de raymond
attention alors il ya pire que les pieds
de rémy
[Rires]
sur l'échelle de l'ue ça c'est un choix
qu'a le garde
ça me trompe mais pour moi c'est la
pétanque ah ouais bah moi je ne suis pas
très bull
allez on va maintenant enchaîner par
deux merveilles
et l'addictif d'enchaîner là là là on va
repartir fort daniel et gilles laborde
daniel et après gilles et ne manquez pas
dans un sens vous allez voir un truc qui
n'avait pas bu de toute votre vie
sur la teneur j'ai alors que j'ai c'est
pas mal mais c'est ainsi c'est un parti
pris les pieds de gilles
c'est un phénomène et c'est sympa mais
je trouve je les trouve pas moche et en
particulier c'est pas les affaires de
l'équipe en tout cas ouais
ah bon vous êtes choix en
coire demande qui a vidé l'extérieur des
pieds pour l épervier alors je joue dans
ses terres et mon mari
et moi côté l'acea
baïla l'objet
c'est un truc de fou alors va démarrer
par daniel à saint tropez daniel à saint
tropez je pense que c'est possible en
plus à des rires oui mais pourquoi
menacerais bah oui c'est vrai ils
cherchent domicile cherche des personnes
cherchent des personnes oui regardez
balle et là à les battre
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
à
non m elle est en train de draguer
nicolas way
[Rires]
tu
as perdu assez de temps comme ça
perdure et les harlequins là les bonbons
à laymont lombez
alors la paire locale message ou le
compère temps mais le petit papier bien
mais c'est vrai c'est vrai c'est pas
trop chaud et vous est ce être ennemis
mais là je dis oui bah oui du pakistan
paroisse à la crème sa fermeture et
pourquoi tentatives ont fait preuve pour
pamiers un petit truc terrible c'est que
dirais tu vas centrale peu après talent
gym au sol
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
mais c'est pas ça la vie c'est pas sa
passat je regarde ce qu'il ya dans
l'émission shape hannut
la mondiale aujourd'hui j'avais pas
qu'ils aient leur mort by à saint tropez
c'est n'aurait pas oui normalement ils
payent pas avec la série va s'en trouver
mais il va que chez les autres et
à skis pas si on le met maintenant si on
attend à non les plis le plus moche et
ceux de castelli sur l'année de ma mère
il a dès hier il a deux parties dans sa
villa à nieppe il a pas un oignon offert
ces îles à une salade d'oignons mondiale
c'est
comme ça mon club il a appelé comme ça
frère non moi je voulais donc là on va
voir ça aujourd'hui malheureusement il a
cautionné à la place de
ballet gabon à la pétanque il voit son
[Rires]
nom mais je n'ai jamais vu ça j'avais vu
des pieds aussi élégant gradine vous
mettrez vos pieds à côté de celui de
gilles à huy et là on fera dans un
instant que le verbe
qui est ce pays
est avec nous non non il n'y a pas plus
beau
restait une chance aux connaisseurs
pourront montrer que je fais vous met au
goût d'animateurs voilà oreo haut quand
même on est professionnel il ce qui va
arriver dans l'émission je le découvre
on va le savoir dans un instant pourquoi
le dire un bon pourquoi le dire a dit
non mais t'es mois bernard montiel
d'abord je veux finir avec les dom
une demande de la direction
bernard montiel
[Applaudissements]
il est bon qu'il savait quoi ça change
de là c'est tout ce que j'aime ouais
mais surtout de maguette jeu sera tout
un pull rose
vous poser la question si j'étais alors
que j'ai reçus fait le 6 à 7 brillamment
avec le public est là
[Applaudissements]
en
direct les 110 ans d'un yacht dingue
alors je descends de
ne pas pas de papa ou le vôtre
[Applaudissements]
papa tu allais qui va descendre de mon
yacht ses gardes face aux enfants en
pleine mer
c'était difficile
à ces cinq là bas
sur la tête de ma mère on dirait que
c'est pas tes y est meilleure en direct
ont mis des iem d'un hangar si j'en suis
le gars plutôt fait plus tard patrick
mercier
ces pages et des pages de notre jeu
mais ils sont beaux ils sont en
réparation ce que j'ai perdu ce tongs le
lie à dos mais
c'est toujours très sexy ça
dans ta sexy non mais c'est vrai qu'avec
ta meuf c'est le premier soir elle boite
on doit
ça les connaît mais je connais ton
paname et sonné alors il ya aussi des
pieds horrible c'est ce qu'ils font les
marathons non mais non je suis avec ma
marathonien dans mes frères il a d y est
mon frère son pied on dirait qu'il a été
rongé par les remords
mais je vous dis non mais sans déconner
adam mais son pied il à l'alcool aux la
variole de
la variole
par exemple dans ce clasico si elles ont
détecté des traces
je vais vous dire moi j'ai fait si l'on
demande à bon oui je suis quelqu'un de
balai vous étiez le corps le
gros rat de l'opéra
[Applaudissements]
fais gaffe de pas l'avoir sur la tête
s'arrêtait à quoi sont
jetés
[Rires]
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
pour moi le couple saint tropez c'est
géraldine maillet et bernard ou très
seyant vous défierait peut-être cible
mais je doute qu'ils soient détrôner
d'une énorme surprise il ya une très
belle surprise
alors on va accueillir maintenant
celui qu'on surnomme chewbacca
dans le milieu pédestre
jeunes bernès
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
est-ce qu'il est fini alors comment
s'intéresser à la
vie et après
[Applaudissements]
c'est là l'idée de la traque aux camions
venus d'ailleurs et
qui dit ça à mike tyson je crois qu'une
fois comme ça et je leur dirai plus mind
de chez dyson
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
c'est un petit accessoire je vais te
dire tu es très bruyant franchement si
c'est moi nulle que ce que je pensais
mais ses
[Rires]
frères ça c'est pas mal mais qui tue est
toujours de la partie avec qui
je la quitte à renier footballeur away
avec des chaussures trop petites donc
c'est un racornie un peu tout ça et ça
au céret mais sinon j'ai des pieds quand
même et les gones n'ont en outre pas ah
ouais alors ça c'est des gros seins
enfin ça va je trouve c'est parce que
j'ai plus moche mais ça c'était bien ça
c'est pire ça c'est fini
que la frères faingaa rentrent en pleine
forêt
[Applaudissements]
les gars t'es pas des animaux qui
veulent manger dessus
vous n'avez pas des poils sur vos
orteils très peu d'armes alors moi j'ai
eu des jeux montre cgd pied magnifique
gm a déjà eu la chance et vous pouvez
demander j'ai de la chance ouais mais la
gauche et défier qui s'ébauche penser
sans merci la fédé pic s'est penché sur
mon berceau exactement ce que j'avais
j'avais une jeune fille en eux fiancé
rester des heures à regarder mes pieds
j'aime bien me regarde plutôt le film
d'anne on préfère regarder
traîné les pieds
mais je regardais que mes pieds à
sorties vous avez mes films dans le
monde et les pieds du
gave et j'avais 17 ans à l'époque
non c'est normal ça ah oui mais non mes
fans ou conseil
oui elle est très en jambes et les pieds
à dire un couteau suisse sont des
conneries
alors tes pieds sont bons je veux dire
pourquoi ils sont beaucoup comparé à
d'autres pieds car on n'est pas plus
beau que voilà vous allez voir c'est un
truc de ouf c'est y est on dirait des
boîtes à outils
non mais c'est des stein essayé tu vas
te mettre là parce que tu m'as tu as
tous les alors tous les spécimens
mettez-vous là
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
et
on va accueillir ben jama castration sa
troupe
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
vraiment j'ai bardot
c'est quoi composer car c est ce que ce
qui est sûr c'est que tu vas peut-être
la table et par alexia laroche joubert
pour le prochain non
mais je te le dis allez regarder et
regardez comme les leaf au japon marche
bien décolleté était magnifique je veux
que je te dise je te jure que thébaux
comment ces du 45 ha oui d'accord mais
tu fais pas du 47 du coup parce que
j'ai la jambe cassée je prends un peu
plus grand allez maintenant on enlève
ses chaussures
maîtresse pas possible tu t'es fait
piquer par un moustique
frère s'était fait piquer par une
abeille ses pieds je sais pas moi vous
toujours ici pee wee malheureusement
depuis la laisser en direction est et
pékin au ciseau
qui l'ont fait en travaux pratiques
dominique
senequier de grand mère
c'est la dp qu'ont vécu quoi tu vois
mes frères vous sera possible mais tu
joues au foot pieds nus dans les alpes
mais si je veux rien faire c'est comme
ses frères mais cette quinzaine piété
fin de toutes les femmes ont vu thê binh
a oui oui bien sûr oui au mariage après
le mariage mais il n'aime pas trop parce
que finalement on écrit on trouve ça
dégueulasse un match deux pays
avaient sombré laisser la cornée certes
ils ne connaissent pas possible à midget
a pris de la cortisone sur techno
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
ah ouais non mais elle est franchement
été extrêmement élégant c'est une bonne
idée tout à l'heure j'ai une classe
naturelle
c'est que moi je t'adore c'est toi si tu
as vraiment tout va mais j'aimerais bien
évidemment juste nicolas pour toi merci
en faire un groupe en soit je suis
humble nicolas pour toi qui est celui
qui symbolise le mieux la classe à
classe à saint tropez à saint tropez oui
ou même à tunis un
haut ballon
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]